i haven't played one of these in a while
the eastern bullet
arena oh i might play mysterious experts
who also
just joined i think and we're similar
ratings
oh maybe not hello to more people giallo
trumpet boy how's it going
uh i'll play london
reverse london
i'm playing viciously i want to go for
this move
maybe this move
oh did i just lose a piece i just lost a
piece oops
and i have to trade queens okay not the
best start
i'm down a ton of time
oh and i played f6 the opponent didn't
take it
okay so i'm still alive kind of
had to prevent this
good move very good move
okay 12 seconds left
really not a great start but still kind
of surviving
not really
hmm
okay that's what i needed
wow what a game wow
dirty flag dirty flag let's go
oh what a way to start the stream
welcome everyone hope you're doing well
i was really dirty
i mean the whole game i was just down on
time until the end
but even like this position
and 12 seconds left i was down a piece
and then yeah so this moment this was
actually kind of tricky because rook d8
it looked like it was winning that i was
able to take and the rook was hanging
finally caught another streak oh hi
i've been out on a forest fire wait what
a forest fire
i hope you're okay hope you're staying
away from the fire
um welcome cash money thanks for the
bits
okay let's continue um
i don't know if it's going to be
feasible to try and win this
chess network in the lead i think my
goal is to say chess network
which it's going to take some work hi
eric oh hi how's it going
oh something something something
ogareshon okay we kind of have a reverse
grand prix
this is playable oh i'm getting forked
opponent misses it well this king f2
what is king f2 let's take a knight
take a thing okay
so the goal is to get the queen here and
eventually checkmate
or with a pawn
i really like my knights
let's take a rook take a pawn
take a knight next
okay z oh z z nation
oh no not z nation but someone
some almost mate
there we go okay thanks for subbing oh
nuclear nuclear nuclear raven
saying zee i have not yet played the
rosen attack i only discovered the rosen
attack last night
which is like an actual opening i am
making some za
do you want any oh oh like z as in pizza
um i actually had sushi earlier so i'm
kind of full
but thanks for offering
maybe you can share it with other people
in the chat
oh free queen a lot of people giving
away their queens
okay i want to win a pawn i'm close to
mating
i just need something other than my
queen like my knight
oh no my rook okay
no time to waste yeah i have to catch up
to the chest network
again
oh i should have taken okay and here i
can take
let's go in okay let's not go in let's
just complete development
always playoff three
bullet time i never have any idea what
is going on
oh yeah it's kind of fast paced
i don't always know what's going on
either just gotta play quick
yeah we both berserk this game and bring
my knight here and then here
a lot of pins in this position
oh it's a thousand bits from bowling
eric the first time
just watched your performance in that
road to chess monster tournament where
you play
nice first
oh my queen my queen's trapped
okay i was losing the final position but
that's okay
thanks so much i'm bowling 24. oh glad
you glad you enjoyed it
yeah it was um i was in good form that
tournament again
let's start for gambit time
okay stafford gambit declined
okay solid position
i want to play queen f6 probably
don't want my bishop to get trapped
my knight wants to find a new home and
somehow
in some way what
oh knight g5 okay the king's taking a
walk the queen's still attacked
there's no g4 thankfully i can take this
active king i probably just want to run
away
yeah let's run away
uh-oh don't mate me
yeah g5 was the only legal move there
okay both queens hanging
oh there's a pin that's nice
oh no my bishop okay that was nice
a nice little mating pattern let's
preserve it again just trying to catch
chess network
oh free nights okay i like free nights
i like free pawns
oh i don't like giving away free bishops
though
okay so that was a big trade
what's material material is equal wow
alpha zero time so i want a fork
or i want to trap the the thing there we
go
i want to win a bishop
so if takes i play rook g1 okay here i
pawn storm
i always play off three
so if takes i play this and takes
oh hello friend how's it going finn sack
thanks for starting
okay let's pin the bishop
[Music]
king will come in and now i'm fighting
mate
blackson's looks long almost so funniest
looks long
threading made again
okay back to tournament let's go
where am i i'm somewhere oh i'm 17th
place
berserk again play more chess
okay one of these
h3 would be a bad free move no i want to
play 95
okay i still have something
this is playable
i've had a few mouse slips this game
already oh does that move
oh i'm losing a thing
i'm playing a strong player too okay
this is
this is trouble
so i have to avoid trades
and move quickly
trying to direct focus to the king side
as much as possible
another good sign though
some progress
let's go wow another dirty time scramble
and
i was down on time i was down to
material but somehow that worked
okay trying to catch up i've been with
every game so far
let's keep it up grab time
i don't know what this is but it looks
fun finished your latest swiss
tournament youtube video
the second one congratulations thanks so
much appreciate that
okay not quite sure what i'm doing here
i just want to play solid
play quickly maybe h6
um yeah the knight will find a home on
g5
and queen finds the home on f6 attacking
the knight kind of
attacking the queen you can take
96 hitting both pawns
pretty queen i like free queens
i like forks too
take that in castle
you should have enough time here
a very unfortunate mouse slip
[Music]
ah
there we go okay
okay got the job done hey it's c.l smith
thanks for
for the raid sale smith appreciate that
if you're just joining i'm playing
eastern blitz
there's working pretty much every game
oh let's position
um play
let's play this line
have to be careful
just want to trap a bishop
oh no my rook
i lost well played i barely know the
rules
very well played as my first loss
okay 19 minutes left
ah two weeks too slow but gg
okay how the night was working streak
i'll try and keep it up
still still 19 minutes to go
yeah preventing black from playing e5
get some kind of stonewall setup
it's a stone wall with kind of an
improved bishop
f6 i'll play bishop h4 pinning the pawn
i'm attacking the bishop probably d5
here
even d6 not sure if this is good
[Music]
play c4 so now i'm defending the pawn
very confusing position
okay so black sax up the exchange
but down on time
that's a free queen and nothing was
defending that queen
now i'm winning the rook as well
[Music]
oh my queen okay that was bad
thankfully i still have good chances
there we go
okay let's go sixth place
so top ten um oh
i was gonna say the goal is to catch up
to chess network no berserking this game
serious game time i think he plays a
london no he plays
whatever this is um i'll play a
semi-slav
play bishop here bishop and then c5
okay
um have to be careful i have to be very
careful about my queen
that's a very annoying pin it's very
hard to remedy
now i have a bishop
i take that
okay still alive
that was a good move and jerry's tricky
bring the bishop back
oh no my rook well he didn't take it
wow jerry's showing mercy but what to do
in this move and this move
a very confusing position i think i'm
okay
this could have been a lot worse that's
still scary though
this is really scary go eric i'm trying
i'm trying
my time
wow i dirty flagged him i'm so sorry
jerry
jerry outplayed me and then was up on
time
i could have traded rooks in the end
there but
okay so catching up but i'm probably not
gonna win this
29 points out of first
berserk again i'd like to finish top
three
that's a reasonable goal okay we have a
stonewall dutch setup
idea g4 bring the bishop back and then
g4
so i'd like to castle queenside
so we're trading everything so i just
want to open the position
the d-pawns pinned
now this pawn is going to hang and
everything else is hanging as well
this is now hanging as well okay that
was a nice game
hey top three let's go okay the goal is
to catch jerry
um only only 15 points behind
i'd like to berserk but let's play
budapest or whatever this is
london opening time
okay so i want the rook aligned with the
queen
no tactics quite yet
oh the free bishop there's a free bishop
on d3
we both missed it
okay let's minority attack
it's going to be a very positional game
oh i just dropped a pawn for nothing
oh that's kind of unfortunate
so i'm down the pawn i'm up a little bit
of time
there's not too many active plans here
unfortunately i could try this
idea eventually rook d2
yeah this pawn is weak now i win this
pawn
now rook e2 is a plan
a lot of time i can take and then take
in rook b3
i think i'm winning a pawn now yeah up
upon
attack this thing
this should be a pretty straightforward
win
just walk the king
here we go
okay so 50 points
and 20 are the first just under 12
minutes left
so i late joined i late joined 25
minutes late this tournament
we're playing playing first place okay
important game
play the bishop d6 line
yeah this is a more kind of positional
line
i'd like to focus on the king's side
it's kind of a risky move
probably not a great move
oh okay that was i was just a blunder so
i'll be down the exchange
and g4 is coming
yeah this is very unpleasant
my c pawn is weak what to do
knight b8 oh let's take this
i'm down a lot of time
but i'll fight
i don't mind trading queens
bring the knights into the center
[Music]
still down a lot of time
lights are tricky
really
okay we drew oh oh i maybe could have
flagged my opponent
man i was having trouble moving i ran
out of like desk space for my mouse
or my mouse ran into my keyboard
basically
um anyway okay
life goes on let's be here let's play d4
okay this is interesting it's risky from
black
it's a free rook kind of
be safe okay as safe as possible
knight defends a rook attacks a queen
okay this is nice knight escapes queen's
almost trapped
hitting the bishop the bishop was
trapped actually there
and this is meat okay that was really
nice
okay so 55 points on chess network at
69.
berserk again let's play e4 this time
grand prix time
play this line queen f2
knight a4 was better there
so e5 maybe f5 soon
or maybe not oh it almost works
really almost works
yeah let's um let's go for the sack
because this is this is so sweet the
queen has to go here and then
i just win a queen now i break through
as well
this is really nice oops
accidentally paused there that's a nice
game
maybe dubious play there but got the job
done
so about seven minutes left
so i've lost one game i barely know the
rules
which could have affected the whole the
whole course of history
does it begin stafford gambit maybe
oh this line so this is a dubious
variation
okay looks playable
i'll try and attack
good move
yeah white's being very ambitious here
if i took there's rookie one
go after the knight oh my rook is
hanging
opponent misses it okay so i'm alive
i'll play this move
[Music]
okay weird position oh that's meat okay
that was nice that was really nice i
probably was gonna flag if my opponent
didn't get mated
oh i'm only 10 points out of the lead so
that's only two bizarre wins away
play a london again
yeah this is a pleasant structure
wow castling queen side okay let's
attack
i'm gonna play b5 at the right moment
oh i'm getting punished here
somehow oh but the file is now open
okay that's a good sign
let's not get mated it's running mate
now
[Music]
no that was the worst possible move that
was the worst possible move
ah like nice nice chances in that game
as well
okay second loss 63 points
yeah if only okay nobody's working this
game
so we have whatever this is called
oh neither 4 is nice move here
i'll play f6
put the rook on c8 threading this
whoa that's clever
very clever i have f5
king of fate the bishop should be stuck
yeah i'll sack the queen
that's complicated
oh my knight oh i have this move
oh oh it's this is such a fancy game
95 rook d8
i really don't know what's going on in
this game
oh my bishop
i'm much worse here but still fighting
nah my rook ah
oh i collapsed oh chess network's in the
lead now
wow and i oh i got passed
i got passed by my previous opponent oh
that's not good
okay uh that's berserk and let's try and
finish on a good note
yeah this is called the schmidt defense
objectively it's dubious
yeah for for this reason oh but this is
not playable
okay preventing castling
this oh no oh no i just got mated
oh no that's double check two
i was so focused on bishop a6 oh
that was so bad i to i had to block the
file
okay final game no berserking let's
finish strong
and this has been a roller coaster
tournament
okay this is interesting play d5 and
then
probably f3 h4h5
rip just got here to see that guess i
gotta leave now
yeah you can leave now you might want to
close your eyes
i don't know what's about to happen it's
taken
just knight e2 and g4 and g4 h5 is a
plan
hmm still play h5 and then
get the knight to f5
h6 was a good move
it's kind of a weirdly closed position
starting to take almost queen will go to
a1
very weird position
i won connect 4 i hung a bishop for a
moment
there black on the exchange
oh the tournament's done so this is not
counting for the tournament
um but it's counting for some reading
oh okay queen with check thankfully
where's my mate
where's my mate okay i'll just stop
black from promoting
okay
back to tournaments chess network did
not
quite make it
congratulations teacher for you
so i finished in fourth yeah i had a
good run
but then a very um rough finish
i kind of crumbled that was a fun
tournament though
i might post that whole thing on youtube
i don't know what i'll call it maybe
chasing chess network
i'll call it something so if you're
watching in the future on youtube
thanks for watching subscribe follow on
twitch
and i'll see you in the future